on va revenir sur les propos tenus par
véronique genest est bien sûr julie
lescaut voilà qui a fait une nouvelle
fois parler d'elle elle est interrogée
par jordan de gaza pour télé star elle
s'est confiée sur son train de vie elle
a assuré avoir des économies de côté
pour les dalits cependant le confinement
mais elle a également révélé avoir
besoin de dix mille euros pour vivre
minimum alors ça a été un déferlement
s'est fait défoncer vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez à ce que s était
maladroite dire ça ouais et vous allez
me dire aussi si vous sérique plein de
gens qui se posent la question et
pendant qu'ils regardent vous comment
vous faites est ce que vous êtes
angoissé par là l'avenir est ce que vous
pensez que voilà il va falloir fassiez
un autre travail plus tard peut-être
même tout de suite nous pour certains
regardez
on le sait les stars n'ont pas forcément
le même train de vie que nous entre
appartements de luxe nina secondaire ou
dépenses en tous genres la pâture à la
fin du mois est souvent salée c'est sur
ce sujet que l'actrice véronique genest
a souhaité s'exprimer au micro de jordan
de luxe si elle indique avoir dû puiser
dans ses économies durant cette période
de crise sanitaire personnellement
j'avais une réserve à que j'arrive au
bout de ma réserve
c'est sur le montant astronomique de ses
charges que les téléspectateurs ont
beaucoup réagit des charges fixes qui
sont énormes j'ai ma mère a chargé l'ex
femme de mon mariage et bond des charges
qui à en croire véronique jeunesse
pourrait atteindre presque dix mille
euros certains mois ci montfaucon bien
pour vivre beaucoup d'huile par mois
ouais bah oui facile une somme qui
laisse imaginer le montant de ses
revenus à leur argent les stars
sont-elles déconnecté
[Musique]
bah oui évidemment elles sont hors sol
parce que elles vivent pas dans le même
monde que nous et encore moi je me mets
dans dans un niveau qui est moi aussi
hors sol mais je suis moins hors sol que
c'est sarlat moi je fais j'essaie de
faire attention parce que je vis dans la
vraie vie je vais faire mes courses au
supermarché non
sifflé dans ma famille on a des métiers
normaux on voit et je vois que je vois
exactement ce que c'est et moi j'ai peur
du lendemain et je fais attention et
j'ai mon enfant à élever je vais je mets
de côté je suis pas dispendieuse qua non
mais c'est alors qu'ils ont mais mon
corps je sais que toi ça te rend fou pas
assez compliqué à la sa vie où elle
faisait des julie lescaut à 130 milles
140 milles l'épisode si je dis pas de
conneries donc forcément pour être dix
mille euros mais quand elle parle a
annoncé 120000 euros faut dix ans pour
gagner 120 mille euros et elle a dit
quand on n'y arrive pas et que 10000
euros mais si légumes mais ce qu'on sait
d'intention cédé à perte annuelle pays
faisait face à je me suis tu as déjà
payé un échange d'épousés minimum
quelques mois le record mais
bien de quel mandat elle va tt le moment
dans la ville
pendant ce qui veut dire que ce soit à l
est pas mais tous les gens pas il n'est
pas
équipé ses des enfants qui se met tous
ensemble moi dans mon nom dans mon
groupe c les enfants qui se met tous
ensemble belle image et un son pour
payer leur maman parce qu'on la sort et
les abandonne pas leur mère vous après
s'il vous faut dix mille euros par mois
tant mieux pour elle si lui faut dix
mille euros par mois moi je sais que ou
moins une faute 2000 par mois 2200 s'il
ya quelqu'un qui se la pètent pas on
peut tout lui reprocher vous voyez ne
pas l'aimer c'est quelqu'un qui se la
pète pas et qui a le coeur sans amasser
mais à l on peut pas entendre qu'elle
respecte vous levier mais qui tanguait
qui prennent cette s'emballe par mois ou
800 balles par mois ils entendent ça il
faut dix minutes pour vivre elle
touchera pas la peine
samba kimba cuisson balagué timide
c'est là mais rien c'est parfois faut
arrêter d'être démago jet ou chat infâme
de défoncer cette faille est ce que
parce que parce qu'elle a simplement
répondu à une question les réseaux c'est
vrai que c'est lundi c'est n'importe
quoi elle a l'honnêteté de répondre à
une question et tout le monde lui tombe
dessus et ensuite faut arrêter
l'hypocrisie dix mille euros c'est
énormément d'argent c'est vrai il ya
très peu de gens qui gagnent ça mais il
ya aussi énormément de stars qui gagne
dix vingt trente fois cela par mois donc
voilà faut arrêter l'hypocrisie elle a
effectivement énormément de charles et
je pense pas qu'avec dix mille euros
elles vivent la vida loca je pense pas
qu'elle prenne des jets privés je pense
pas qu'elle admire dans des restaurants
gastronomiques tous les jours oui c'est
beaucoup d'argent mais c'est la réalité
alors
d'accord mais c'est votre réalité si
elle si elle a besoin de dix mille euros
c'est qu'elle s'est mis dans une saison
soit sur l'avenir des organismes
intervient alors qu'est ce que je vous
interdis envie d'habiter avenue vie et
toi tu fais dans mon verre sylviane
convient pour un agent sous tu me donnes
bien tu verras tout cumulé je dois être
à 5000 euros mais c'est beaucoup des
rasets voilà donc ça m'a dit il c'est
une petite 6 le stade
j'avais besoin de 10000 euros avec ce
que je veux servir d'un million rigaux
je roulais en cherchent mais je roule en
porsche et ses voyages partout et je
veux mettre un train de survoler la
ville bernard montiel
c'est notre avis plutôt mais c'est le
tracé prévu taconné la gauche c'est le
train de vie qu'elle s'est mis vous avez
vous pouvez pas en tant que dix mille
euros c'est pas beaucoup d'argent et les
auront jamais dadis alors leader avait
arrêté de regarder quand on se dirait
raymond mais je suis absolument d'accord
avec guy pas de démagogie à l'envers de
la même manière que moi je trouve
qu'elle ne se plaint pas elle explique
elle fait de la pédagogie mardi l epad
mais tout le monde n'a pas les moyens
mais ses parents dans l'ehpad il ya
plein de gens qui gardent leurs malheurs
maman laure brunet en galère dorje
absolument pas dégarnir c'est justement
sur ce guide heure c'est par plaisir
d'avoir payé mélissa elle dit pas le
contraire exige et je dois payer les
pattes pour ma mère donc voilà c'est
environ 3500 à 4000 euros par isabelle
jarry des tur où l'eau les détruit 6,7 à
bout difficilement sa belle et sociale
des français même 500 grammes à rougir
guillaume c'est dégueulasse procès
d'intention pendant cette fin nous fait
il est diplômé en peuple
[Applaudissements]
ouvrir l'accès sur les problèmes de coût
et de pouvoir d'achat dont moi je
voudrais savoir et maintenant
concrètement combien tu dépenses tous
les mets moi je t'ai dis moi je fais ce
que tu leur niche est connecté mais la
suite répondu parce que cette réponse je
vais être content voilà j'ai mon sur mon
salaire de chauffeur-livreur 1900 balle
par mois dès 9h ou paraître ce que je
fais ici je les ai toujours dit ici j'ai
dit je mets de côté je rembourse ma
maison presqu'à la retraite quand je
vais avoir mes mille cinq cents balles
de retraite je ne veux plus avoir de
loyer à payer là donc je t'ai dit tout à
l'heure entre 4500 et 5000 balle
parlement faire tel c'est en plus et
finir tête je fais lancé l'appel à des
jeunes aux clauses
rtl je travaillais du lundi au dimanche
sans arrêt je faisais 150 euros bruts
par par par émission sur arte elle dit
mais c'est pas dix mille euros bassima
non c'est pas dix mille euros j'ai
jamais eu
de schumi est déconnecté week end mais
moi je pense pas du tout vous avez vos
pancartes mon prénom je ne pense pas du
tout que ce soit une question de
démagogie ou quoi que ce soit moi je
suis complètement d'accord avec raymond
un moment donné c'est pas parce que tu
gagnes des milliers des sens que tu es
bien l'homme mai déjà alors justement
c'est ça que j'avais à vous dire
j'allais vous dire que juste à
l'application peut être aussi un respect
pour les gens qui ne gagnent pas la même
semaine et qui peuvent avoir les boules
parce que ils galèrent dans leur vie
donc moi je suis pour la discrétion ne
pas donner envie aux gens et je pense
aussi que les stars comme on dit comme
comme sin star soit disant eh ben les
moments saveurs aussi se réadapter
peut-être à la vie normale comme en
quatre jours ça s'arrête octobre et là
je pense qu'ils paient lors de ces
moments qui savent pas revenir à la vie
normale
pas grave tu es à la vie normale je me
tourne vers manama
on n'avait pas ça marche on l'a toujours
dit vous allez gagner je j'ai énormément
d'argent mais bon on l'a dit la même
minute parce que c'est vrai que benjamin
il ya des pays à des périodes d aller où
tu adores gagner la flambée oui plus de
1 million d'euros par an oui bien sûr
voilà déjà nommé ray lahood rémois
raison c'est que c'est totalement
inaudible d'entendre quelqu'un qui a
gagné à devenir pendant alors un an deux
ans 5 ans 10 ans des milliers voire des
millions d'euros et qui effectivement
arriver un stade de sa vie entre
guillemets expliqué qu'elle s'en sort
pas c'est là que 2000 euros alors ça ce
discours là il est fort et il n'est pas
la mèche c'est en gros ce qui ressort et
moi je m'étais voilà donc ça n'est pas
audible après la vérité c'est que quand
on est dans un cercle ou un cycle comme
ceux que connaissent et les animateurs
et les chanteurs mais n'a jamais tant
j'ai besoin d'un charmant est
intéressant donc on est dans un certain
6 ou est relativement tu t'étais emballé
dans un effectivement tu fais ta vie
n'est pas la même que le commun des
mortels c'est un fait comme ça et là
effectivement c'est compliqué c'est
quand quand tu prends une pause dans la
gueule généralement ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on est tous pareils on refuse
de voir la vérité on dit ça va aller
mieux savoir mieux on s'enfonce et puis
quand on est bien enfoncé et qu'on crie
au secours c'est trop tard et ça c'est
valable à examen il ya plein de gens qui
passent de la question ils disent
comment quand on a gagné des milliers
d'euros moi quand on a gagné ce qu
gagnant on sait en rendant toute une vie
en un an comment on fait pour tout
dilapidé dit alors moi j'ai pas dépit
des mois je suis moi j'ai moi j'étais
escroqué j'ai perdu 4 ou 5 millions
d'euros dont 15 ans il y aura il y aura
un procès qui va se tenir espère que
j'ai récupéré mais j'aurais dû être
mille fois plus prudent que je ne
l'étais évidemment quand vous dire le
contraire mais c'est très compliqué
quand on est dans un cycle avec des gens
c'est un point de vue c'est ça d'abord
on aide beaucoup de gens moi j'ai tous
mes potes et j'ai fait plaisir à plein
de gens mais je rejette pas non faut pas
faire de procès d'intention tu as raison
dans le symbole effectivement en france
et voilà ont gagné en moyenne 1200 mais
nous à sauver les jeux stands mais je
tente jetons juste en tant que ce que
vient de dire s'il est ou non toute une
vie les gens
déjà c'est ce que les gens qu'est ce qui
se dit derrière leur écran si à la gagne
en un an toutes sublimes rituel va
laisser de côté le problème c'est que
vous pensez que ces éternels l'image est
forte et les abbés roenick regarde
salaires mensuels en france 1789 quand
vous êtes à la télé vous pensez que
c'est pour toujours vous pensez que ça
éternelle et vous flambé à droite à
gauche mais là
on retrouve ben moi il faudrait bien 12
me nommez moi
je suis d'accord avec mais c'est vrai
que je me dis voilà que ça va durer
vraiment régime des marins et peut-être
que voilà ça va s'arrimer dire
globalement ça va au bout ou l'arrêter
[Rires]
l'objectif qu'on parlât
après moi j'ai dit il ya des comédiens
jamais ce que tu es comme
comédien moi mon père qui t'a un gars ya
une très belle carrière qu'elle vient
bien sûr il apparaît y ait des centaines
de milliers d'euros dans sa vie non mais
vous enfermer pour baccarat vous faisiez
partie non mais si oui c'est aider sinon
vous avez gagné d'argent prérequis des
mois j'ai guéri guillon ah bah oui mais
on l'a appliqué
les quatre ou cinq
je devrais avoir de l'argent de côté
bien évidemment je sois ici vous êtes
les mieux gérées vous auriez peut
arrêter de travailler là bien sûr ah
ouais ouais
bien sûr vous comment vous avez gagné
leur ai dit comment on faisait gagner en
tout logique je poserai non plus la
question parce que sa mère je vais
maintenant vous aider non mais j'ai
gigli plusieurs dont plusieurs milliers
de rouges sur mignot ou alors millions
de roupies environ nous et aujourd'hui
je gagne beaucoup moins d'argent non
mais c'est pas ça va leur annoncer
et benjamin elle aussi il a paru bien
voilà j'ai tout cramé oui je me suis
fait ce mot qui est aujourd'hui bas
partiellement responsable aujourd'hui
j'étais très heureux de vivre sans
guillemets parce qu'il n'a pas le matap
et sait-on gravillons suffire j'ai mis
mes gmi jeu pas vous en dire j'ai mis 5
à 6 ans amo a accéléré le fait que
j'étais plus le cas stan lee d'avant
alors je dis très bien bien sûr je vis
normalement voyager normalement est
grave ans et s était même si la vente
quoi voilà mesdames était calme et tu te
bats et un tee shirt un créateur
benjamin mais c'est pour ça que ça voilà
gernelle c'est ce que
je me suis même pas posé la question si
ça l'était vient altérer fait dans un
cycle où tu ne peux pas te projeter dans
tous les mois sur ton compte en banque à
200 ou 300 bureaux qui arrive crois moi
que tu te penches projette pas dans le
futur un futur tube pas là tu penses que
ça ne s'arrêtera jamais fou on achète
une maison tous les mois ils seront pas
là quand ils touchent les 200000 il se
rend pas compte comme c'est un 25 ans de
crédit dans français arrivent acheter
varane hélicoptère un machin sa cervelle
non mais je n'écoute et non le voyage
matin mais ces messieurs combat parce
que tu as envie de kiffer mais pour les
gens c'est dur d'entendre c'est dur en
tant que c'est illisible et d'une entrée
dans vos points de la même chose elle a
cherché
à
montrer l élargissant mais je crois que
je crois aussi qu'il est question de
personnalité moi suce et issu d'un
milieu modeste et on a toujours très
bien vécu ce avant moi j'ai toujours
peur du lendemain bon il est vrai qu on
y est pas
créature de vous garder je suis pas
dépensier je n'ai jamais été moi le
premier truc comme j'ai jamais cru à ma
carrière j'ai acheté une maison j'avais
pris un crédit sur 30 ans voilà parce
que j'avais pas d'argent du tout quand
j'ai acheté cette maison au pyla bon il
se trouve que grâce à tf1 tout ça j'ai
pu la rembourser la payer cette baraque
j'ai ça voilà tout le reste donc c'est
du plus et je pense est parée de
l'argent de côté vers l'amont tiennent
énormément non non non ça va ça va ça va
vous pouvez j'ai très peur ça fait
d'être un vieux seul arrêt des comptes
mais oui et il a peur c'est déjà le cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'a fait quand on est seul
gilles verdez où vous êtes outrés moi je
suis recrée d'euskadi vers attendait le
délit très bien votre ville gilbert des
arrêtés
absolument vous m'avez augmenter même
cette année
côté passons je reverrai savent
très bien ma vie bien sûr j'avais donné
mon salaire ici ça me dérange pas mais
on gagne très bien ici et je trouve
qu'il ya une déconnexion ce qu'elle dit
là pour moi c'est honteux et et quand je
vous entends même benjamin je vous
respecte énormément mais les sommes que
vous avez gagné les gens pour eux c'est
une abstraite jeu tous les genres de
légumes et tous les gens qui nous
regardent le 10 du mois ils ne peuvent
même plus aller au supermarché pour
faire plus ou alors faire des manifs
mais non c'est bien mais maintenant j'y
suis à réaliser sont bien les gens ils
ont le fric moi je connais plein de gens
qui adorent the wall rnic de beewi géré
a dit faire l'innocent ces cas là quand
vous entendez avec 10000 euros mais
c'est impossible en tant que ça si elle
disait ma mère à l'ehpad mais qu'elle
prenne un impact moins cher moi je vous
le dit les yeux dans les yeux elle dit
je dois je dois m'occuper ou là le
l'ancienne femme de mon mari qu'elle
diminue qu'elle aille devant un juge et
qu'elle diminue les frères ainsi
impossible dans le monde sa personne
aujourd'hui en france ne peut dire j'ai
besoin de 10 millions vivent c'est un
scandale pour tous les gens qui n'auront
jamais sur un nom les gens y mène est un
nom avoir des 1000 euros non et les
isles ont pas tous des fois on n'osait
pas dire ce qu'elle a dit franchement si
c'est ma vocation
c'est innover sur des
contributions aux impôts à payer les
gueules appuyé l'annexion n'est pas
les gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent
ne paye pas beaucoup d'impôts ou voire
pas du tout à leur payer des arrivées
quant à la toucher son argent mais
l'économie qu'elle a fait payer plus
d'impôts sur ses effectifs et deuxième
étages et revient au canton vous donne
la parole dit des choses intéressantes
bastien mais entre moi et eux nettement
je trouve que c'est un tribunal
révolutionnaire a vraiment épouvantables
mais épouvantable elle a toujours payé
des impôts en france elle n'a jamais
rechigné est là et c'est un peu ça
autant c'est alain giraud signe est ce
que je la connais bien
on est vraiment et c'est pas une amie
est vraiment il est en train de devenir
fou tellement point sur mon roi pourrait
recevoir sa mort d'innocents
c'est venu de par la
découverte des collections niveau
ni ses conseillers non mais c'était de
la bad et la troupe de l'équipe très
discret parce que si vous vous dites
combien vous avez gagné grave ou oui
voilà si vous n'y trouvez vous avez
gagné la salle athéna mais grâce à ses
lignes
bosser des gens vous a décrit désormais
aussi grâce à julie lescaut à laquelle
veut dire qu'il le disait qu'ils se
plaignent
tu m'as demandé moi j'ai dit
non à la vraie question on aimerait
question qu'on se pose tous ses combats
gagnent lui pour
rien dire que que mentir comme tous les
gens qui titille de leurs revenus je
suis vraiment fière parce qu'ils vont
longtemps oui mais je l'assumé
complètement parce qu'il faut expliquer
aussi c'est que c'est des trains de vie
particulier ça vous enfermer dans un
mode de vie c'est un métier on peut tout
perdre du jour au lendemain il ya
énormément de gens autour de vous qui
dépendent de vous que vous payez il ya
énormément de gens qui se font inviter
tout le temps je pense que benjamin a
l'habitude de payer plein de gens voilà
donc ces gens là aussi il donne beaucoup
à georges frêche à mamou quand vous
allez au restaurant c'est toujours pour
vous allez donc pendant dix ans j'ai
kavala invite au restaurant bar s est
jamais on part on va avec castagneto son
égard ainsi des chemins non parce que je
te dise étaient des potes mais c'est
comme si en plus c'est normal vous êtes
un restaurant mais j'ai des copains qui
n'ai pas d'argent je peux leur dire de
payer l'addition c'est que la bande des
chaînes qu'elle est l'addition la plus
folle comme des oeufs d'or voilà un truc
vraiment de marge vous dire c'est s
était alors j'espère je vous dirais
testé à la céleste vegas d'accord parce
que j'avais invité le réseau d'or une
renault et il y avait en baisse de 25
personnes les gens quand ils prennent la
carte ils choisissent le vin et là vous
commencez à transpirer
à las vegas à des vins c'est mon frère
c'est ma d'évincer des maisons qua non
et non et je vois cheval blanc quinze
mille dollars jeudi en panne ordre celui
là passants mais n'ont pas non plus
quelle beauté nord
sa cinquième balle de narberth les vélos
mercier
ouest le pire ouais bah oui mais bon
après tout comment elle c'est l'addition
elle fait combien genre 70 pour cent des
1000 dollars contre est
écoeuré on l'a même pas vu en tous les
honnêtes voit il le dire ils sont nés
honneur c'est la douce folie fait en
restaurant oui on restera par ailleurs
quoi sais quoi d'autre
voulez savoir quoi badienou c'est quoi
la plus grosse folie au restaurant
valent un autre truc de fou que vous
avez l'hôtel l'avion avec quand vous
avez fait un truc que vous avez fait le
fou d'elle ça peut monter au nez si on
les bat
regardant ça faisait ça monte vite à des
prix tout le formule un pauvre ouais
alors que sous l'effet des prix tous les
tâches d'un hôtel taj non ça coûte et je
sais pas c'était très cher bach était à
présent il va c'est fini on sait très
bien que si à 50 ans on voit l'annoncé
peut être je sais pas cinquante cinq
mille dollars la nuit début juin la
ville va dormir
chez moi je te mets à colombo
je pense à toi et tu vas très bien
dormir explique cela après on dit non
ils sont pas hors sol moi j'ai
avec lui c'est qu'il a toujours dit il
son plan paul
vi dont 55 millions lamy quant à 12h tu
as locaux dit le mec qui te dis faut
quitter le champ d
un compte 5000 bulls
jerry regardez moi oui à 90 %